foreign
's in Greenville South Carolina hi
Sharon welcome to the Ramsey Show
what's up
um I am 75 years old a recent Widow and
we have some lakefront land for sale in
South Carolina and I was recently
offered full price six hundred thousand
dollars in physical gold and I am having
a heck of a time finding any good advice
as to the advantages and disadvantages
of accepting physical gold and payment
for the land and I've listened to you
for years and it occurred to me I need
to call Dave and see what he would
recommend
um
okay number one
if this is real
you don't know you laid eyes on a big
giant chest full of gold bullion that's
what I got in my head yeah no no I I
know
I can clarify I know the person who is
offering the deal very well and he is a
wealthy person who owns a large company
that does work in four Southeastern
company so he's legit uh you know not a
difficult person to check out and why
doesn't he just pay you
what do you mean why doesn't he just
close the land I mean sell the gold and
pay you in cash
well I don't I would ask him that
question that's a good question to ask
he told me he has been blind gold he's a
great believer in the gold standard for
the U.S and since he started his company
at 18 and he's 80 now he has accumulated
all this physical gold so sell some of
it and since it's so wonderful and give
me my money give me my money okay listen
here's something let's turn it back
let's turn it and let's be a little bit
nicer okay here's how I would handle it
if I were you okay okay I'm going to
play the uh
I I always play the uh uh you know for
instance in business I'll go oh we're
just a small business we're not real
sophisticated you got to help us out
okay okay so in your case it would sound
like this I'm a 75 year old Widow I
don't even know how to begin thinking
about doing this you're the guy that has
all the money and you're Mr
sophisticated so I need you to help me
out I I don't I can't do this because I
don't know how so what you what I need
you to do is just show enough of it and
give me my money
that's that I can do I because I don't
know what to do with it man and you're
the you're the big gold guy you're
you're you have all the connections you
know how to turn it into money I don't
know how to turn it into money so you
got to help me out here
uh okay well one thing that he's told me
and I also confirmed this was that there
are no tax consequences there's not
doing what yeah there's not so that's
awfully attractive when you're looking
at a six hundred thousand no there's
there's no tax no no no no no no no no
no no there's no tax consequences to it
being gold there is tax consequences to
you selling the land
yes
but like but whether you take cash or
take gold doesn't matter
right there's no taxation because
because it's gold it doesn't make it
have tax consequences
okay but but there's no way I'm doing
this
there's no way you should do this
knowing knowing how much that you work
in real estate I thought maybe you'd run
across that before or you just you
wouldn't recommend it for anything I can
probably get the gold liquidated but I
wouldn't take it
the goal is their issue not my issue I
don't I'm not getting in the gold
business
and I don't want to be in the gold
business for 10 seconds just liquidate
the crap and put it in my account but
the money in my account will have a
closing
okay great it's really it's really
there's no advantage to you and there's
huge potential disadvantages the
disadvantages is you the gold goes down
three days after you get a hold of it
exactly and you know or worse than that
this guy is not who you think he is and
it's a fraud the fact that he's
presenting this is very weird and that
alone raises a flag for me but your your
vouching for the guy I was getting ready
to give you a 25 chance this is fraud
but you've you've narrowed that down to
a five percent chance now because you're
vouching for him but um but I'm I'm
still not doing it there's no way
somebody comes up offering me weird crap
you know what you know why stuff seems
weird because it's weird
you know the reasons feel strange is
because it's strange you know and that
that sometimes you just kind of got to
go with that